foreign
good day everyone welcome and happy St
Patrick's Day I'm Jack Van Horn from the
University of Virginia and I am very
proud to welcome you to this edition of
our
2022-2023 foundations of biomedical data
science seminar Series this lecture
series is supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from
the National Institutes of General
Medical Sciences since 2016 the
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series has focused on the use of
data science methodologies artificial
intelligence deep learning and
statistical modeling as they pertain to
different themes in the biomedical and
Health Sciences this year's theme is
data science and the public health
consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where each week we enjoy presentations
from leading thinkers about the issues
the promise opportunities and hurdles
associated with understanding the
secondary health effects of covid-19
these Inc include but are not limited to
delayed Health checkups and treatments
mental health drug abuse increased
obesity and the long lingering health
effects associated with the SARS
covid-19 virus participants selected for
our biomedical data science Innovation
lab program will leverage these
presentations as vital material for our
culminating in-person Grant project
development Workshop to be held at the
lodge at St Edwards Park in beautiful
Seattle Washington in June of 2023.
today I am delighted to welcome our
speaker Dr Catherine Kim from the miter
Corporation Dr Kim is a health
informatics researcher and expert in
digital health and Community engagement
she received her PhD from UC Davis and a
masters in public health and a masters
of Business Administration from UC
Berkeley and her ba from Harvard
University she is a principal of
consumer health informatics at the miter
corporation which is a non-profit
organization working with government and
private sectors to improve the safety
stability and the well-being of our
nation she is also an adject associate
professor at the University of
California Davis in their school of
medicine and Public Health Sciences
department at miter Dr Kim currently
leads the activate Group which is a
comprehensive model for Equitable and
sustainable digital health for
underserved and Rural communities the
activate program provides technology and
assistance to develop virtual care
remote patient monitoring and digital
health literacy which engages patients
and improves Health outcomes she also
serves as the clinical lead for miter's
age better lab
which is a connector and collaborator
with Academia government and Industry
for aging research and digital Health
Solutions she is a fellow of the
American medical informatics Association
chair of the consumer health informatics
working group and she's received
received numerous awards for her
community engagement and her
participatory research related to
technology and health in continuing with
today's
2022-2023 biomedical data science
seminar series theme today's lecture is
entitled digitalhealth Equity Dr Kim
will discuss the digital Health Equity
including a framework for community
co-production of digital Health Equity
interventions that focused on policies
and other things which interact in a
local context amongst the stakeholders
to deliver outcomes of digital Health
Equity she will also share the activate
project a demonstration of community
co-production on a platform for remote
patient monitoring chronic illness
management and as always we are
streaming this lecture live and for
recording via YouTube If you are
watching on YouTube thank you so much
for joining us also our specially
selected
2022-2023 biomedical data science
Innovation lab participants and alumni
are encouraged to submit any questions
they have via the zoom chat sessions I
will synthesize these questions and I
will ask them on your behalf during the
last 10 minutes or so of the lecture and
with that welcome Kathy we are so
excited to hear from you today
thank you very much I am really pleased
to be here
um with all of you to talk about this
topic which is near and dear to my heart
to digital Health Equity
so let's start with some definitions
um what is digital Equity well digital
Equity is the information technology
capacity of individuals and communities
to fully participate in this in society
and the economy
um uh access to broadband connectivity
is a key component of digital equity and
that's achieved when people and
communities are all able to access and
use affordable high-speed and reliable
internet that meets their long-term
needs there are a number of barriers to
digital equity for all um all
communities and they include policies
from the federal to the local level
practices by technology and internet
companies infrastructure barriers due to
the geography or the built environment
as well as digital redlining which is
the intentional lack of investment in
infrastructure and Affordable Services
for low-income and minority communities
so it's important to start with digital
Equity
um
because there's a real National
investment happening right now to
address these barriers this is funding
that came through last year administered
by the national telecommunications
Information Administration that's called
the Broadband for all our internet for
all
um and this funding has started to flow
to really address the middle mile to
Last Mile connection so middle mile is
really that that Regional level of
infrastructure
um primarily to States and regions to
make sure that um there's there's
Broadband availability and then the last
mile is going from that Regional
infrastructure to the individuals
neighborhoods and Community Based
organizations so they can actually
access what is available to them
so this ntia funding is really in there
are multiple programs that are being
funded
um that again are being
um the the dollars are going to the
States but a really key component of
this program is to address digital
equity and so there are specific
requirements
um that come with this funding to make
sure that there are plans
um so that the communities and the
individuals who do not have access
currently
um are taken care so that they have
access to this infrastructure
um so this is a really important
National topic right now
but now let's talk about digital Health
Equity
um so digital Health Equity obviously
depends on connectivity and many people
will say that uh Broadband connectivity
is a social determinive health that
access to the internet is has become a
critical component of people's ability
to access health and health care so the
definition of digital Health Equity is
access to digital Healthcare appropriate
design of solutions and the benefits and
outcomes of digital Health experiences
so it's not just access to digital tools
but it's actually making sure that those
Solutions the interventions the programs
that we create are appropriate and
accessible to all of our communities
so um there are several Frameworks that
have been proposed
um for thinking about digital Health
Equity
um one of those Frameworks would give
these sort of Five drivers that are
important to pay attention to
um similar to what you saw in digital
Equity it also includes the policy
instructional drivers
it includes system level influences like
the public health and the healthcare
settings in our community it includes
community and social factors such as the
role of family and friends and
community-based organizations
and of course there are individual
influences such as an individual skills
digital literacy health literacy and
their motivation to use
um these available digital Health
Solutions and then there are
characteristics of the platforms
themselves such as are they usable are
they accessible so you can see how this
these concepts are really large they're
big scale Concepts right these are not
um things that you can address sort of
in a silo they really require lots of
collaboration across multiple um
disciplines and multiple multiple
sectors of our
um of our community
the other definition that I wanted to
share is what is the digital Health
ecosystem you know there's so many terms
that we use to refer to these things
sometimes it's Telehealth sometimes it's
telemedicine
um you know it's it's really the the
broad ecosystem that supports connected
health
um so course connectivity is essential
but it may include systems that you're
familiar with like Telehealth
um telemedicine but it may be
technologies that are used
um in you know in the the delivery of
very complicated
um uh uh services like remotely guided
surgery it includes real-time patient
monitoring and that may include for
acute services like hospital at home and
intensive care monitoring but it may
also be for things that are more managed
by individuals so self-care
self-management for things like chronic
illnesses
it also includes the Technologies
themselves that people use so data
collection from sensors that are either
in the environment in the ambient
environment or that are worn by
individuals and then it includes some
really important infrastructural
components like data exchange across
devices and platforms which you can see
just from those items that are in the
list above much of the data that is in
each of these systems is not necessarily
shared with other systems or with the
patients themselves and often cannot be
aggregated in ways that make it easy to
compute or to analyze
um it also includes the ability of
people to access health information and
treatment information
um so can people get the information
when they need it or can it be delivered
in ways that um that are accessible and
offered at a time
um when when it's most beneficial
we also need to be thinking about
accessibility
um for um of course our diverse
population has diverse capabilities and
capacities to interact with technology
so we need to be thinking about all the
ways that we might interact with
technology including things like voice
mobility issues
um other assistive
features and capabilities
um and then things like virtual and
augmented reality to make
um both treatment and health information
health education more accessible and
interactive and consumable by different
types of people and then Financial
Technologies we know that Financial
Health or financial stability and
security are very tightly linked with
with health status
so this is not necessarily a
comprehensive inventory but it just
shows you the breadth of Technologies
and systems that are part of that
digital Health ecosystem
foreign
so I'm going to tell you a little bit
about this project called activate which
is a community co-designed digital
Health Equity innovation
so activate is a project that was
started as a partnership of University
of California Berkeley and miter that
really started in 2020 when it was
becoming clear that large Health Systems
academic medical centers Urban Health
Systems were very rapidly able to Pivot
to Telehealth and virtual care virtual
visits when covid-19 really was gaining
a foothold in the United States
um within weeks when I I was at UC Davis
health So within weeks we were able to
um get have you know thousands of
patient visits via Telehealth
this was not the case in underserved
communities and particularly in
community health centers
um in rural areas and in in regions
where they are the primary source of
Health Care and so we were very
concerned um that that these community
health centers were going to be left
behind and they would not be able to
continue providing services to the
residents that were really dependent on
them for care
um and so we were fortunate to receive
an anonymous donation
and to to put up the system
our vision was to create an equitable
digital Health platform for Rural and
underserved communities to put the tools
for health and well-being into the hands
of the person and their health care team
and the way that we saw ourselves
completing that or contributing to that
Vision was to co-design and Implement
digital Health Solutions to really take
the advantages of these new technologies
and and bring them to the community but
also to remove the barriers to impactful
use
so our goals in this program were to
demonstrate this activate platform in in
um in three Health Centers we actually
completed four community health centers
that are using the system now
um and that was done in 2021 and 2022.
and then to disseminate that model
across the state and the and the nation
um and create a roadmap to
sustainability and that's what we're
working on this year
so as I mentioned um we were
co-designing this program with community
and so our we used a participatory
design framework which really relies on
um the the principles that
um anything that you uh create for
people
um has to really be um in intensively
involved with them both at the very
beginning in defining the problem
defining the challenge and understanding
um how those people live and work
and then you need to embed with them
throughout the entire process so from
design to testing to implementation to
evaluation and Beyond and so that's what
we did we worked with the health center
staff including providers nurses medical
assistants health coaches community
health workers and Outreach staff and we
work with patients of the health center
with their family members and caregivers
and other community members who were not
receiving Care at that Health Center in
all we worked with about 25 individuals
on our co-design team over the course of
six months to produce this
as I mentioned we were really um trying
to bring the access to technology but
also recognizing that there are a lot of
barriers to adopting digital Health
Solutions for both the community clinics
as well as the individuals
um the health centers that we work with
are in communities that are rural that
treat primarily uh treat a large
proportion of agricultural workers
um and so we needed to make sure that
we're addressing all the barriers
because if you have a solution
um and and people are faced with many
barriers to using your solution any one
of those barriers can put can you know
stop the program from being successful
so we need to take a very comprehensive
approach
um to addressing all the barriers that
we thought might get in the way
so some of those barriers include things
like having a digital health program
that is adapted to the culture in the
setting
um so many of our evidence-based
programs like chronic Care Management
disease management programs were studied
and developed in academic medical
centers often in settings that have more
resources
um you know and in research projects so
lots of things provided for you but if
you were to try and do those kinds of
programs in a small community health
center that doesn't have the resources
it may not be as effective as what you
saw in research so you need to really
adapt what you do to the right to to the
level that is appropriate and and
acceptable to the culture and the
setting in which you're working
a second barrier for the clinic is
Technology Solutions that will really
work
um they have to be optimized for how the
clinic works the work the clinical
workflows the staff and the level of
experience that they have
um and they have to
um really be attendant to the
infrastructure that's in the clinic
for example this next one is complete
and interoperable data well if you have
an electronic health record system and
you're trying to add remote patient
monitoring or you're trying to do
Telehealth visits or you're trying to
bring in other kinds of Technology if
that doesn't interoperate with your
electronic health record if the data
doesn't even go into your electronic
health record it causes um you know
problems in terms of the workflow in the
clinic on the availability of the data
to the providers when they're offering
the care and it limits the ability to
analyze that data later to know whether
you have a effective
efficacious or effective program
um complete and interrupt over data it
is a real a really critical uh barrier
because we see many of the solutions
that are implemented in the health
systems although they could be
integrated they often are not because
there's an additional expense or there's
just additional resources that need to
sort of keep those interfaces running
um the next barrier is the availability
of of time and the experience with
digital programs for the clinic staff
and providers many of them may be
individually technology Savvy may be
using you know technology for personal
use but they may have had no experience
in creating a digital health program
that works in in their health center
and the clinics are very understaffed
um you know in kova they were even more
understaffed than on the right on a
normal basis and so just having time to
think about how they would create a
program or having time to implement that
program was really constrained
um and then let's move to some
individual barriers many individuals in
rural areas who are low income who are
um uh who may not speak English as a
first language are also the ones that um
don't have up-to-date Computing devices
smartphones tablets laptops or who don't
have a connectivity
um so
um you know they they have both Health
disparities and they have digital
disparities so we find that many
individuals that are being served by
these Health Centers will tell you they
have smartphone
um but when you ask can they use that to
download a recent app
they they can't because they didn't have
enough data in their data prepaid data
plans or the smartphone is an older
version and hasn't been upgraded and so
actually cannot
um cannot use Uh current apps
so access to up-to-date Computing
devices and Technology uh sorry and
internet access is a real concern
another in in our program was a
disparity around access to remote
patient monitoring devices which I will
tell you about in in a little bit but
most health plans do not cover remote
monitoring devices so things like
bukometers connected glucometers
connected
um uh um uh blood pressure machines
other kinds of things that that you know
people may need to have on a daily basis
to to manage their condition
um individual digital health literacy so
many of these participants in rural
communities if they haven't had access
to these kinds of Technologies in the
past
um don't have experience and so they're
not sure how to pair devices how do you
how do you use Bluetooth how do you know
whether you're you're um you know your
internet is actually working how do you
you know connect things so their ability
to have both the digital skills and the
health skills combined may be a barrier
and then finally stable and sustainable
funding many people didn't realize that
prior to covid-19 community health
centers were not reimbursed for for
Telehealth they were actually not
allowed to provide Telehealth to
patients in their own homes they could
be a clinical site and connect to a
specialist for a specialty consult with
the patient in you know in their in the
clinic room but they were not allowed to
provide the Telehealth service directly
to the patient so it's only because of
the public health emergency
that allowed clinics to do to do
Telehealth and to be reimbursed in for
it
and so there was no funding store since
no resources for
um for health centers to do this
um now that we all have experience in
doing Telehealth many of the health
centers are able to to do it and do it
well
um you know the hope is that there will
be funding sources that continue
um so that we can continue with the
progress that was made during the during
the pandemic
so understanding that we were trying to
co-design a platform
um to allow for digital Health in this
community health centers and address all
of these barriers this is what we
created
so this is just a very simple rendering
graphic about what we did this is a
platform that is HIPAA compliant so it
does
um it you know it does uh provide for
both privacy and security
but it is flexible as well and it was
important that this is flexible because
as a research and code design project
it was not an attempt to create a
commercially available system that would
replace what clinics were doing but
rather to be an adjunct to be
complementary to the Technologies they
had to provide additional capabilities
and to make sure that all of their
technology worked together
so that it could be streamlined and
efficient
so
um the platform integrates remote
patient monitoring devices
those devices were selected by each
Health Center for what they were hoping
to use what they had experience using
and in the cases where there was
insurance coverage like under Medicare
devices that would be actually covered
by insurance if that was an option
so we have seven devices that we have
integrated that are in use
um we provided a pairing app so that um
uh participants who had these devices
could download this app
um be able to automatically pair the
devices with our system that would
identify the patient and identify the
device and so that data could be brought
together in our servers and matched to
medical records
so all that data goes into electronic
health records systems
and the workflows are are streamlined
and integrated so that it can work
alongside with the virtual visit system
if the health center has that as well as
other devices if their preferences for
the health center for how they want to
run this system
um and finally their interfaces
um user interfaces for the program
manager as well as the participants so
they can see their data so the the
program manager can run
um you know analyzes and to see the
status of all of the patients that are
are participating in their program and
then there's some analytics
um and um and ways for people to to see
um as a group how how the the patients
are doing and what the outcomes are
um so this system is used by
participants themselves these are all
participants in in the first phase of
this where all participants with
diabetes and hypertension
um and then the teamlets in the health
center and the teamlets are um the
healthcare provider
um the medical assistants health coaches
and community health workers if they
have them
one of the really important things here
is that the teamlet needs to really work
together and it was a model that not all
Health Centers use but it was important
that they work together because this is
a technology adopt in part a technology
adoption program and so it needs to be
adopted by the staff at the clinic and
it needs to be adopted by the
participants and so you really have to
address all of that infrastructure and
all the barriers that we talked about
previously and you have to have people
on the teamlet who can make sure that
that all of those things are being taken
care of
the other important
um development here is something we call
the digital Health pathway
and this is the operating model for
person-centered self-management and care
coordination
this is a way of modeling all of the
touch points between the clinic and a
participant
and we created this for each condition
it's customized by condition as well as
adjusted for each Clinic
um and as I said it Maps every touch
point and the importance of that is to
one make sure that we understand the
clinical workflow the operational
workflow
um the the how the Technologies should
interoperate so that that's all mapped
out as part of the planning process and
procedures are created so that once you
implement the program it works for
everyone in the clinic and it works for
each of the participants
um the other important Concept in the
digital Health pathway is that with all
these touch points you um you really
proactively think about
um how you can have each action be
digital first
um and that means that there is a um a
capability within the technology to
handle it in an automated way or in a in
um that the technology has the capacity
to do that but it's not digital only and
that's important because if you're going
to be person centered you need to
recognize that not everybody has the
same appetite or interest to use
technology for every touch Point people
still want a personal relationship with
their health care provider and so they
may not always want a virtual visit they
may want to have you know an in-person
visit with their provider they may also
want to use the telephone at certain
times and not do a a video call or there
may be times when um you know they they
really want education from a health
coach and not to to read
um or view you know something online so
you have all these touch points that are
digital first mean there's a capability
for it to be done using the platform but
that's not the only way people can
interact
and then finally it's combining the
right touch with the right Tech so that
you really tailor the support and the
technology
to the touch point and to the purpose or
the goal that you're trying to
accomplish
so this is a model that helps you to
understand that and helps you to to
build for that to design for that and
implement it
so we do have outcomes um we have a
paper that's currently in review for the
outcomes so I'm not going to share the
outcomes here but we will say that it
has achieved very substantial
improvements
um for hemoglobin A1C for those with
diabetes and blood pressure for those
with hypertension in these Health
Centers so it is fully implemented
um and we have two health centers that
have a substantial number of patients so
it's in use with several hundreds of
patients in two and then two additional
health centers that are just online now
and and starting their enrollment of
patients so we've had very good outcomes
so now I want to talk a little bit about
the data science implications of digital
Health Solutions like activate
and this is research that we are are
currently undertaking
um uh we started this this research
project last year and it's called the
community connectivity framework for
digital Health Equity
and this is a a research project to
really understand
um uh how do you in how do you develop
and Implement digital health programs
that will achieve Health Equity outcomes
um and there's not a lot of evidence
um actually about how you create those
programs
or even what the outcomes
um are that you should be measuring to
know whether digital Health um uh
improves or
um impacts equity
um so there are some Frameworks um one
of which I shared with you in at the
beginning of this talk but there's not a
lot of evidence
um the second thing is the Frameworks
that that are available are not focused
so much on implementation their focused
on sort of make sure
um that uh that we can conduct research
right they're explanatory models or
explanatory Frameworks
so this was intended to be a very
pragmatic framework that helps Community
organizations
um and particularly underserved
communities understand how to develop
interventions in ways that are
evidence-based and that in ways that you
can assure that they're going to
accomplish uh the equity outcomes that
you're hoping for
um and so there are um some some really
key components here one is that digital
Health the digital Health Equity relies
both on the supply and demand right
these are economic Concepts where the
supply of
um uh not only connectivity but digital
Health Services needs to be
um needs to be there
um and when you talk about underserved
communities
um I you know shared in those barriers
that we don't have adequate Supply
actually on either of those things
um there also needs to be Demand on the
the part of the communities themselves
so that's knowledge of the available
Solutions and the driver of motivation
to use them from both the individuals
and community-based organizations
in delivering digital Health Equity
Solutions
um you you know we also chatted about
how multi-sectoral you know
collaboration needs to be a component of
planning these kinds of things because
there's a whole ecosystem underlying the
delivery of digital Health Equity and so
Partnerships are really crucial
um to these kinds of interventions
um the the creation of these programs
implementation and achieving outcomes
also depends on the local environment so
what um what policies are impacting you
not just at the federal or state level
but at the local level
um what is the local environment like
for Innovation for partnership
um for delivery of Technology
um and so there's this whole backdrop of
the local context that also needs to be
taken into account
and so it's a complex set of forces and
interactions that need to occur to
create a successful intervention and
activate was an example of this
um it was an example of increasing the
supply it was an example of
um uh increasing demand
it was partnership
among a university a private you know
non-profit research and development
organization with community health
centers and members of the community to
create a solution to deliver that
solution and then within the the context
of covid-19 where there was a
recognition that we needed Telehealth
and digital Health Solutions in the in
the community health centers and policy
changes such as the public health
emergency waivers that allowed us to
actually Implement such a solution
so it's an example that illustrates how
you need to take into account all of
these um these Concepts when you're
creating a solution
so in that in with the backdrop of all
that complexity though
um uh what you know how how could you
actually
um sort of take advantage of data
science
so
um there there's
um a wealth of real world data
um in uh you know we have clinical data
from electronic health records we have
remote monitoring data more frequent you
know more frequently now than has been
in the past
um but in projects like activate and
others we have person reported
observations
these might be things like um you know
text messaging or
um you know individual tracking
um self-tracking applications you know
those kinds of data sets that are now
becoming more common we also have
environment and climate data right that
we know has a great effect on on health
and particularly chronic conditions
um so what's the weather what is the
level of air pollution and water
pollution
um you know hottest temperature and heat
um uh or or natural disasters affect
people's Health at particular times
um we also have social determinants of
Health
um and I will point you um specifically
to this citation at the bottom that's
the um from the assistant Secretary of
planning and evaluation for Health and
Human Services this is a review that is
is maybe a particular interest to this
year's data science Innovation lab it
was a scoping review that we conducted
and published on data elements for
research on the role of social
determinants of Health in coronavirus
2019 infection and outcomes in the U.S
this report
shares you know uh from the research the
kinds of data sources that that
researchers were able to take advantage
of including things like clinical data
remote monitoring person report
observations
environmental data but also social
determinants data not just at the
individual level but at the population
level data that comes from census data
that comes from National
um you know cohort surveys data that
comes from indices that are calculated
um population level measures about
social determinants in in States in
regions
um or even down to the neighborhood
level
um so these population level data sets
are also important uh sources of real
world data
um but also the business and policy
environment right we have lots of data
about that come from the commercial
sector and being able to access those
data would are would be very important
to help as well as policy particularly
with
um the internet for all the federal
initiative and the ntia funding lots of
data is is being currently collected at
both federal and state levels about
connectivity about Broadband speeds
about barriers to access
um and um and making that data available
for analysis is an important aspect of
the program
so when you think about all those
different sources of real world data
that might help you to ask questions and
I just offer you know a couple of
relevant health research questions that
um the the health centers
um that Health researchers might be
interested in um related to the kinds of
um data that we have inactivate so for
example what are the factors that
contribute to a health condition or
outcome using not just what was created
in the data sources that were created
and activate but also these other real
world environmental and Commercial data
sources
um Are there natural groupings of
participants and can we use those
groupings to learn uh more about
triggers that precede a particular
condition or outcome as I mentioned we
know we we hypothesize that in um
weather conditions do impact
um you know people with cardiac
conditions people with
um uh pulmonary conditions respiratory
conditions but also the interactions of
those kinds of things also affect
diabetes and other conditions so what
are the natural groupings of
participants
um with their clinical and individual
characteristics interacting with the
environment that would help us to
understand whether they have a condition
um what the um what the particular
outcomes might be for them or what might
trigger a worsening or Improvement of a
condition or outcome
and then can we predict the next episode
when the next episode is likely to
happen
so um these are you know questions that
you might consider as you think about
your own research
um and the data sources that you have
available to you
um but
um what I'm asking here is to think
about what is relevant to your community
to your providers and to the populations
that you're hoping to impact with your
research
so as you consider all these different
data sources again as you can tell I
always come back to ecosystem
um that there this is really an
ecosystem for digital Health it's an
ecosystem of Health for our communities
and and for um people who are developing
um Technologies or trying to analyze
um the information the data that we get
from them
um this is a Continuum of the right
technology and the Right Touch as I
mentioned before we thought about this
concept as in the development of
activate there are things in healthcare
that that require Personal Touch
um and may require
um in person or at least
um trusted relationships to do things
like setting personal and clinical goals
things like addressing barriers to
digital and health self-efficacy
um you know uh things like shared
decision making among patients and
providers
provision of medical interventions and
and procedures
and then addressing
um other kinds of barriers to care that
may require more Personal Touch
um but there's lots of technologies that
we can take advantage of some of the
data collection technologies that we've
already talked about like in in sensors
but medical devices as well
um and then interoperable and computable
data right making sure that that data
from Real World sources can be used can
be
developed in ways to make it computable
and interoperable for use by the
Healthcare System
and a different computation and analytic
techniques
um as we think about you know machine
learning and artificial intelligence we
need to also be thinking about uh
fairness and bias in our algorithms
um assurance that AI is is
um uh providing appropriate
um uh uh Direction and will be used
appropriately
um and then you know other kinds of sort
of ethical
um ethical moral and legal issues
Insight Generation
Um uh again thinking about decision
support thinking about applying what we
learned from our algorithms
um into the practice of of
self-management of improving your health
and of the provision of Health Care
um thinking about the policy lovers
um again federal state and local levels
and then making sure that um self that
individuals can use all of the
technology and um the the knowledge that
comes out of technology to apply it to
their own personal situations to do
self-management to do care coordination
so it's a balance of the right
technology and the Right Touch it's not
um just you know you are either high
tech or high touch you really can be
both but as long as they're balanced in
the right proportions as you go through
interacting with individuals and
communities
foreign
so I I will stop there
um and be open to questions but I hope
that um this this talk has has brought
some information to you about why
digital Health Equity is important
um and relevant
um to those of you in in data science
um and uh brought you some some things
to think about as you proceed in your
own research
um using data science to improve um
health and health care
and I will
um just let you know that there are
references to all the citations that I
provided in this talk
Kathy thank you so much and I want to uh
just invite any of our participants here
that are watching on Zoom to send in any
questions they may have via the chat
feature and um I'll take a look at those
and ask them on your behalf uh with with
Kathy Kathy one of the things which I I
want to kind of start at the end of your
presentation that you talked about which
I think is kind of important especially
in the context of
kind of how we often think of as data
Sciences trying to remove the human from
the loop many times and I liked how you
brought in the notion of a personal
touch
um where the human is firmly in the loop
and um what can you share with us any
like stories of that as a successful
strategy that's uh you know has been
born out of this model that you've
described
absolutely
um I'll give two examples
um and that's a wonderful question thank
you for asking that um Jack
um so I'll give you one example from our
design process
um and that is that we had you know
patients and family members who were in
our co-designer team
and one of those participants gave us
told us a story
um she said that you know she has um uh
high blood pressure among other things
and her doctor had told her go get a
blood pressure machine you could just go
buy it you know at the drugstore
and you need to be measuring your um
your blood pressure every day and taking
care of yourself right and then let me
know you know what your readings are and
how it's going so she was doing what she
thought they told her to do she went to
the drugstore she bought a device she
was measuring it every day
um and when she went to talk to the
doctor she said well how's it going
um and you know how are my readings and
the doctor said I don't have your
readings she thought that it was
automatically somehow going to the
doctor
and you know she didn't she didn't know
that she had to buy a particular kind
that allowed her to connect through
Bluetooth and set it up like no one had
explained that to her
and then it turned out that her blood
pressures had not improved and she's
like well I you know I was watching the
numbers but she didn't really know what
the numbers meant and she was making
some assumptions about them but no one
had sat her down and said well this is
what they mean and what you should do
about it when you see these readings so
all of these kind of points of of
failure for her led to her feeling
ashamed you know that she had done
something that was you know she felt
ignorant she felt like you know and
she'd wasted all this time
so it led to her feeling badly
fortunately she's the type of person who
didn't let that stop her and she said
I'm going to be involved in this project
because I want you to learn from my
experience right what not to do for the
next patient
so it's that Personal Touch that no one
had asked her what she needed to know no
one had said what might get in your way
no one had checked in with her about how
it was going
um there were just a lot of assumptions
made so that personal touch someone just
talking to her would may have you know
uh sort of interrupted that cycle
um early on to make sure that it was
going to be useful for her and for for
the doctor I I think that that usability
thing is so important I mean we sort of
assumed that people are I don't know
that they're they're just aware enough
these days right oh yeah just go to the
store and buy the device and it it will
just magically present itself about how
you're supposed to deploy it right and
for some folks that may be more
difficult than others and we shouldn't
make those assumptions absolutely
um the other example that I would give
is a I think a very simple example which
is now we have hundreds of patients
taking their blood pressure as many many
times and taking glucometer readings
many times and I'm sure people have said
well what is the doctor supposed to do
with thousands of readings right we have
10 000 measures now what's the doctor
supposed to do with all of that right
what I mean how you know they're not
going to look at every one of these
readings so how do we make that
something that's useful clinically
um so one of the things that we did was
to be able to graph that information
to set um to implement threshold levels
that the health center
um determined were ones that you know
they wanted to have information about
about people and to provide um patterns
and trends
um because what a clinician will tell
you is that this an individual may have
on on average you know a higher blood
pressure and so trying to get them to
some arbitrary standard blood pressure
may not actually be the right decision
right but if you don't know what their
what their um their Baseline normal
blood pressure is you may just be kind
of beating up on them get it down get it
down but you might not realize that in
fact they have gotten it down right so
um being able to provide that
information
um in a in a way that is personalized to
the individual's particular health
status and can show a provider what
those Trends are
um on a you know daily weekly monthly
basis is what makes that information
useful and so those are the kinds of
um you know data visualizations that we
are able to provide and now in that
activate
um you know program manager
the provider with the health coach and
the uh the nurse can actually look at
all the patients and at a glance
understand
um what those measures mean and can make
decisions then with the patient based on
on those kinds of Trends so there again
the the um importance of understanding
the real problem for the clinics staff
and providers was critical to designing
a solution that was going to work for
them and that that came from being
embedded and designing with them
foreign
Kathy you talked about like the you know
folks that you're focused on in rural
communities
um you know and sort of this topic of
familiarity with technology kind of is
gonna vary widely right if you're in a
big urban area you're probably seeing a
lot of the technology if you're in a
rural area you know maybe you're not as
exposed to it
um on the other hand there are people
working in those rural communities who
not only might they not have access to
the technology they might not understand
it but they also may have some
reservations about using it and I'm
thinking about undocumented workers and
they may have some serious worries about
utilizing technology that might expose
them as undocumented is that this might
be a sensitive topic but I'm curious if
you have any experience with this or I
mean from you know being in the part of
California you're in you might see this
from time to time I'm curious absolutely
that's a really big concern among
particularly among agricultural workers
because many of them are undocumented or
have family members who are undocumented
and so providing information even going
to
um you know a hospital
um or you know in in the case of covid
coming to get a covered vaccine there
was a lot of cause for concern about
what information will I have to give
what will they do with that information
will they ask me questions that put me
at risk for my family members at risk
um and so you know signing up for the
affordable connectivity program which is
the federal you know program to give
every household access to the internet
a lot of people are are concerned about
doing that because they have to give
information to the government so this
partnership at the local level between
Healthcare organizations and Community
organizations along with these sort of
state and federal programs is really
critical because it's the local
community-based organization that is the
trusted entity to those individual
members of the community
so it's really important that those
trusted entities the the um be involved
in delivering the message and an
assisting individual people so that's
part of this community connectivity
framework this is why you have to have
that partnership as part of Designing
the program and developing and
implementing the program
you kind of introduced your talk